المستجدات الميدانيه في قطاع غزه اعلن
الجيش الاسرائيلي انسحاب اللواء 55 من
المظليين في قوات الاحتياط من منطقه
خانيونس جنوب قطاع غزه وقال الجيش
الاسرائيلي في بيان ان هذا اللواء اتم ما
سماها مهامه العسكريه في المنطقه واستبدلت
به قوات من وحدات اخرى واضاف الجيش ان
اللواء 55 عمل على مدار شهرين دمر خلالها
70 فوهه نفق في خان يونس وعثر على وسائل
قتاليه عده وقتل عددا كبيرا من المسلحين
حسب زعم
البيان من تلبيب معنا مراسل الجزيره امين
درغامي امين ما الذي يقوله الاسرائيليون
في الجانب العسكري بالاضافه الى سحب هذا
اللواء ا الجيش الاسرائيلي قال بان سحب
هذا اللواء جاء بعد اتمام مهامه بحسب
البيان الذي اصدره وقال بانه على مدى
شهرين اتم مجموعه من العمليات من بينها
تدمير نحو 70 فوهه ال نفق وا اضافه الى
عثوره على عدد من الوسائل القتاليه
وقتله عدد من المسلحين بحسب تعبير هذا
البيان قبل ذلك الجيش الاسرائيلي اعلن عن
اصابه خمسه من جنوده وضباطه في قطاع غزه
خلال الساعات
الارب الماضيه وقبل ذلك ايضا كان الجيش قد
تحدث صباح اليوم عن عدد من العمليات غربي
خان يونس في جنوب قطاع غزه وتحدث ايضا عن
عدد من ما قال بانه تم تحقيقه خلال
الساعات ال
2ب الاخيره لكن الان هنا في اسرائيل ما
يدور وهو عثمان يتمثل في الجدل حول
صفقه تبادل الاسرى مع حركه حماس هناك
انتقادات واسعه ل حكومه بنيامين نتنياهو
في تسييرها لهذا الملف هناك وسائل اعلام
اسرائيليه تحدثت عن ان مسؤولين اسرائيليين
شاركوا في او يشاركون بالاحرى في هذه
المفاوضات انتقدوا تصريحات نتنياهو امس
التي وضع من خلالها خطوطا حمراء في مساله
اتمام هذه الصفقه وتتمثل في عدم
قبوله مساله سحب القوات او وقف اطلاق
النار في غزه اضافه الى اطلاق سراح الالاف
من الاسرى الفلسطينيين وقال خلال لقائه ب
دوي هؤلاء المختطفين بان هذه الصفقه يتم
العمل عليها لكنها لن تاتي او لن
تتاتى دون يعني بشكل يمكن لاسرائيل من
خلاله ان تقدم تنازلات ايضا كانت هناك
انتقادات لبنيامين نتنياهو جاء على
لسان زعيم المعارضه لبيد الذي قال بان
بانه وفي ظل حكومه نتنياهو عاشت اسرائيل
لربما الازمه الاكبر منذ المحرقه النازيه
بحسب تعبيره وقال بانها لن تصمد بعد عام
2024 وبان نتنياهو كان عليه ان يتنحى وان
يرحل منذ زمن ايضا من خلال تصريحات اخرى
جاءت من المقربين طبعا من نتنياهو هنا
الحديث عن
اتمار بن كفير رئيس او وزير الماليه
الاسرائيلي قال بانه لن يسمح باي وضع
تنتصر فيه حماس وسطت الاستطلاعات للراي في
الحقيقه جاءت على صفحه صحيفه معاريف قالت
بان
96% الان من الاسرائيليين عثمان
يرفضون اتمام هذه
الصفقه دون او مع تقديم تنازلات لحماس
بالاضافه الى ان واحد من كل ثلاثه
اسرائيليين يريد بان تتم هذه الصفقه
واخلاء او استعاده المختطفين لكن مع عدم
منح حماس افضليه او تنازلات وفق هذه
البيانات لاستطلاعات الراي امين درغامي من
تال ابيب شكرا جزيلا لك